Hey guys, how's it going, it's Justine and today I'm unboxing something
that my friend Francesca bought me for my birthday which,
At this point was quite a while ago,
But I've been saving it because I wanted to open it for you guys because this is super, super cool
It's called Furbo.
And basically what it is, is
I know a lot of you guys have probably seen nest cameras,
And other types of dog webcams,
But this one
will, actually, give your dog a treat.
You can take photos and videos, there's a treat toss, and there's a two-way talk.
Live video streaming,
two-way audio barking alert, photos and videos, and smart privacy.
Let's check it out!
What I'm most excited about is being able to give Matty a treat while I'm away.
I'm not a huge fan of talking to him, because I don't want him to get confused
and get upset because he thinks that I'm in the house and I'm not.
But I absolutely love the fact that it is streaming live video,
Oh wow!
It looks really good too!
So here it is,
still comes with the Furbo.
Oh, Matty's coming in here.
He knows somethin's for him!
Got a charger,
and it looks like this is just a simple micro USB charger, which is fantastic.
Plug it in.
Download the app.
And that's it.
So it says, "Getting my Furbo ready"
so it looks like it's going to be connecting it to Bluetooth.
and that's whats happening, so it's--i'ts finding it right now.
*beep beep*
Here's the setup process, it says it takes 3 to 5 minutes.
So I guess I'll just, be right back.
These aren't exactly treats, so I don't think he's gonna be that into it,
but, at least we'll be able to see if it works.
This has like a nice little air-tight seal to it so your treats won't get spoiled.
Oh! My setup is complete. That was way less than 3 to 5 minutes.
*gasps* It worked!
It's up!
Ok, so you can slide a treat,
ok, ok.
You do this to slide a treat.
*mechanical whirring*
O-oh my god!
It threw several treats!
Matty, want treat?
Look Matty, watch! Ready?
Take a picture--hi baby!
What do you think?
Does your dog--I think he loves it?
Maybe if we got some better treats in there, you might like it?
The problem is he doesn't want to eat dog food!
Well this is what I'll do,
I'm gonna put a good treat in here.
Ok Matty, these--these are good treats.
Get the treat, Matty!
C'mere, look!
There you go, honey.
That's for you!
He took it, he took it, he took it!
So the key here is, uh, not using dog food, and using delicious treats.
Good boy! Yes, that's my man!
That's my main man!
My tip to you guys, is use your dog's favorite treat.
These,
way too small.
It shot out like 50 of 'em!
Well thank you guys so much for watching, a huge thank you to Francesca for getting me this incredible device
because this is awesome!
I'll put a link in the description if you guys want to check this out, or get one yourself for your dog.
But in the meantime, I'm gonna go clean up the dog food mess that I just made. *laughs*
Matty, come here honey!
C'mere baby!
He knows that I don't have anymore treats, so why would he listen?
(Music)